In the first passive video
we talked about the most passive
of passive modes of transport - simple diffusion.
We talked about how small, uncharged, non-polar
molecules can easily pass through the membrane by diffusion.
For example, carbon dioxide or molecular oxygen
will pass through the membrane most easily
by diffusion.
They are small enough to slip through the small empty spaces
in the membrane and since they have no charge or polarity,
will be able to pass through the entire membrane.
Then we talked about medium variants,
such as water molecules that are small enough to pass
through the spaces in the membrane, but have polarity.
They will not be able to pass very easily,
but they will be able to leak.
We also talked about things,
which will be very difficult for them to pass through the membrane.
These are the loaded frequencies,
here we have some ions - sodium ion,
potassium ion.
Though they are small, they will interact hard
with phosphate heads,
with this charge, it will make it difficult
passing through the membrane.
In this video I want to keep talking
for passive transport.
Remember that passive transport does not use energy.
And the particles move in the direction of their concentration gradient.
We will talk about ways in which passive transport
can be relieved
for some of these molecules here.
Their passive transport
will be facilitated and facilitated.
That's what we'll be talking about in this video.
Let me first find a place where
to write it, relieved diffusion.
I will write it,
relieved diffusion,
relieved diffusion.
The previous video was for a simple diffusion,
we will now talk about how we can make it easier.
What do you think,
if we had to invent something,
to facilitate these particles -
water moles or ions,
to move in the direction of their concentration gradient,
what would it be?
You might say, "If we did not have to deal with
with all this,
with all these hydrophilic heads and hydrophobic tails,
and hydrophilic heads here. "
"This would facilitate movement in the direction
of the concentration gradient. "
Exactly such an invention has also appeared in nature.
Practically there are tunnels through the membrane.
One way in which the diffusion can take place
is through the use of protein channels.
I will write it in an organ, just like that.
"Protein channels."
Example of a protein channel
it may be here.
It can be a specialized channel
for water,
this type of channels are called aquaporins.
"Acvoporini."
It's just a protein channel for water.
You see there's that hole on top.
Let's say we have more water molecules
outside the cage, than in it.
We want to move them in the direction of their concentration gradient
or perhaps we have a higher concentration of solute here,
there will be osmosis.
Water molecules will be more likely
to move from the outside to the inside,
than from inside out.
We can have water molecules that come in here.
They do not have to deal with the membrane at all,
just going through the aquaporine
and will come out inside the cage.
We have similar protein channels for ions.
This one can be for ions.
Let's say it's sodium,
here are sodium ions.
They are loaded, they will have difficulty passing through the membrane.
But this protein channel may be specific for sodium ions
and allows them to pass.
As we will see when we learn about neurons,
protein ion channels
are extremely important for boosting
electrical or electrochemical signals.
Ionic channels can also have activating doors that open and close
Under certain conditions,
which may be different in different parts of the cell.
These protein channels may be open
or closed,
depending on the conditions in which they are located.
This is key
for processes in neurons,
as we will see in the next videos.
Another kind of diffusion can take place
through the so-called transport proteins.
I will talk about the transport proteins, but it is important to stress that
people still learn how they work.
I will draw a membrane here.
I will draw the medallion and
carrier protein in the membrane.
This is a transverse cut of the membrane.
The dual phospholipid layer is almost ready,
now the carrier protein. The way I draw it no
shows exactly what the transport proteins look like,
but gives an approximate idea.
Something like that.
If the particles want to move in the direction of their concentration gradient -
Let's say we have a higher concentration on top.
I'll take some hypothetical particle,
which has a higher concentration than the bottom.
Particles can get stuck or get in
the department here that will make it
the transport protein to change its shape.
Let's see if I can draw the altered shape well.
It can change its shape.
This happens when we pick up particles from above.
When the protein "sees" that there is a load,
can change its shape to this one.
He'll turn around.
Let me take another tool.
Today I have a problem with the tools.
The carrier protein can be reversed.
It was open above, but now
and the load that was
gathered from above,
falls inside the cage.
It is a passive transport because
all these particles move in the direction of their concentration gradient.
If we did not have a cell membrane here,
the particles would move in that direction.
We would have more particles moving in that direction
for a given period of time, than
in the opposite direction.
But the cell membrane stays in the particle path,
however it can
to ease passive transport.
It can facilitate diffusion.